GARDEN.
TRAE, THANK YOU FOR TAKING A FEW
MINUTES WITH US.
WE APPRECIATE YOU.
>> GOOD TO TALK YOU TO, ERNIE.
>> WELCOME TO PLAYOFF
BASKETBALL, HUH?
HOW ABOUT THIS FOR A DEBUT?
>> IT'S FUN.
WE ARE IN THE MECCA, NEW YORK
CITY, TIMES SCARE.
IT'S FUN.
>> TRAE, WHAT WAS GOING THROUGH
YOUR HEAD WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
CROWD AND SAID IT'S REAL QUIET
HERE.
YOU KNOW WHAT THAT FEELS LIKE.
>> YEAH, YEAH, GOOD QUESTION,
SHAQ.
I THINK IT WAS -- MINE, YOU KNOW
YOU BEEN IN THE BIGGEST STAGES.
WHEN YOU ARE IN THE ZONE AND
EVERYBODY IS CHANTING F-U, I
DON'T KNOW IF Y'ALL HAD THAT,
BUT I HAD IT IN COLLEGE AND
AGAIN TONIGHT.
I MEAN, IT GOT QUIET AT THE END.
AND FOR ME, I WANTED TO HEAR THE
F-U CHANTS AGAIN.
>> YOU KNOW, TRAE, YOU GUYS ONE
OF THE YOUNGEST TEAMS IN THE
NBA.
DID ANY OF THE VETERAN GUYS OR
THE COACH TALK TO YOU ABOUT,
HEY, THERE IS A DIFFERENT LEVEL
OF INTENSITY GOING INTO THE
PLAYOFFS?
>> YEAH, OF COURSE.
ESPECIALLY WITH GUY LIKE LOU,
GALLO, THE GUYS IN THE PLAYOFFS,
GUYS THAT HAVE HAD SUCCESS IN
THE PLAYOFFS.
AS YOUNG GUYS IN OUR FIRST
EXPERIENCE HERE, WE HAVE BEEN
LEANING ON THEM A LOT.
THEY HELPED US A LOT.
>> TRAE, YOU KNOW, IN MARCH
THINGS LOOKED DISMAL.
THEN ALL OF A SUDDEN THERE IS A
COACHING CHANGE.
THERE IS A REJUVENATION AND THEN
THERE IS NATE McMILLIAN.
WHAT WAS THE TURNING POINT THAT
MADE YOU GUYS GO FROM, YOU KNOW,
NINE TO TEN GAMES UNDER .500 TO
A TEAM THAT'S NOW A GAME WIN IN
THAT FIRST PLAYOFF DEBUT?
>> GREAT QUESTION, KENNY.
I THINK FOR US IT'S JUST THE
BELIEF IN EACH OTHER.
COACH M.A.C. HAS DONE A GREAT
JOB IN PUTTING BELIEF.
I MEAN, ENCOURAGEMENT,
ENCOURAGING GUYS TO BE
CONFIDENT.
I THINK